some people are very upset over Donald
Trump's pick for the Supreme Court what
are they so upset about
eople are freaking out they are freaking
out because they don't understand those
top areas whether it's abortion or gay
rights or citizens united that people on
the Left tend to be concerned about
there's really not gonna be a change
that's because the court especially
Chief Justice Roberts respects precedent
especially when people have come to
depend on previous decisions after a
quarter-million gay marriages and 45
years of legal abortions the courts
unlikely to reverse itself on those
issues I will nominate judge Brett
Kavanaugh but if Kavanaugh replaces
Kennedy there will be changes individual
freedom
what does Kavanagh mean for that he's
great they're probably better than
Kennedy retiring Justice Kennedy
sometimes ruled against individual
liberty like when he said it was okay
for a Connecticut town to grab suzette
kilos property in little pink house
because the developer who might pay more
in taxes wanted her land Kennedy voted
for the bad guys he voted to take away
the the property from the people
Cavanaugh could very well be the fifth
vote to overturn kilo one major area
that people might be upset about is
affirmative action we
to use the Supreme Court as a weapon
against Cavanaugh could provide the
fifth vote to overturn that 40 year old
experiment with using racial preferences
to promote some kind of nebulous
diversity lawsuit against Harvard
University for discriminating against
Asian American applicants that case
against Harvard's racial preferences may
reach the Supreme Court soon and the
court may end affirmative action the
court with Kavanagh on board may also
toss out some gun restrictions
he has written one of the leading lower
court opinion expanding the scope of the
individual right for armed self-defense
he's not a gun nut he's a
constitutionalist Cavanaugh has a
history of reining in government
regulators all these alphabet agencies
that increasingly intrude in people's
live he has written at length that the
government keeps doing things that it
doesn't have the power to do the
Constitution's separation of powers
protects individual liberty at his
nomination announcement at the White
House he talked about how the separation
of powers is there to protect Liberty
that's fantastic
I think libertarians will like the push
back on government excess but Cavanaugh
does side with government on one form of
excess the government was collecting all
of our metadata all of our phone records
Cavanaugh ruled that he was just fine
with it he said that the NSA is
justified in collecting metadata on on
Americans as part of the he volunteered
to write that he was enthusiastic that
this serves a critically important
special need preventing terrorist
attacks but the government says were
aware of no instance where the program
discovered an attack that's his worst
case now it's it's unclear how that
extends beyond the national security
surveillance area he has a lot of good
opinions on police needing a warrant or
laws being drawn so broadly that
prosecutors are convicting people who
are not guilty clearly he defers to the
government on national security grounds
but most judges and justices do anyway
at least on other forms of regulation
Cavanaugh has a strong record of not
deferring to government we have a moral
obligation to act on climate as a judge
in DC Cavanaugh voted the
strike down some environmental rules
some EPA regulations where the staff
just said we're gonna do this that's
right I mean I like the idea of clean
air and clean water there's their
federal laws that protect that but in
the last decade the the EPA has taken a
lot of liberties like it's their job
clean the air clean the water EPA does
not get a free-floating power under the
Constitution or otherwise to do what
they think is best
it's Congress's job to say you know our
air isn't clean enough here's how you
should be doing your job EPA why is it
better for Congress to do it Congress is
elected and if we don't like what it's
doing we can fire it that's the way the
checks and balances work and that's why
it's so important that courts hold the
bureaucrats feet to the fire the
libertarians should definitely be happy
with Cavanagh it's not going to agree
with us all the time certainly but no
justices or judges do the fact that
we're looking around the edges to see
what sorts of things we can disagree on
shows how far we've moved in 10 or 20 or
30 years right at least now people and
judges talk about limiting government
now regulations out of control that's
new compared to the last 10 20 or 30
years